joining us now Texas Republican Governor
Greg Abbott uh Governor welcome back to
Fox News Sunday want to start here you
know we've got the lead negotiator for
the GOP in the Senate coming up Senator
James lenford um the White House says it
needs more money he says they're
pressing for policy changes what's the
number one thing you would tell Senator
Langford you need to get the border
under
control we need to stop the magnet that
is enticing people to cross our border
illegally coming from more than 150
countries across the entire globe
and the way that you do that is to deny
Asylum to anybody Crossing between a
Port of Entry uh make if if you have a
valid Asylum claim you can go to one of
those ports of entries of which we have
29 just in the state of Texas alone you
must make them uh seek Asylum uh from
either the country they are fleeing or
from Mexico or some other safe country
they go into that would dramatically uh
cut down on the number number of people
that you see uh coming across the border
every single day the second thing that
must be done is they must end The Catch
and Release policies that the B
Administration has put into place cidly
the law already prohibits uh the the
mass uh uh allowance of people getting
out and wandering the country for years
before they ever have to go to court the
B Administration simply is not enforcing
that they must hold the body
Administration responsible
uh and and deny them the ability to have
Catch and Release Governor are you in
talks with the bid Administration with
the White House at
all so Shannon know this and and that is
I I provided uh eight letters uh to the
Biden Administration which includes the
the president and mayorcas and I I
personally handed a letter to President
Biden and to secretary mayorcas when
they showed up in El Paso Texas
outlining five things that they could
could do that would eliminate the crisis
at the border Shannon in response to all
eight of those letters I've heard
absolutely nothing from the Biden
Administration okay you have heard from
New York city where the mayor there has
announced uh a lawsuit he says the tens
of thousands of people that have been
bust in by you to his City uh it's
overwhelmed and so they've announced
this lawsuit this week that is against
the bus companies that brought the
people there they're citing this New
York law that says any person who
knowingly brings or CA es to be brought
a needy person from out of the state
into the state for the purpose of making
him a public charge is going to be
guilty of a misdemeanor they talk about
fines and it goes on to say they have to
support them at their own expense so
they're suing these 17 bus companies for
more than $700 million you're not a
party to this but do you worry that this
is an attempt to shut down companies
that would do business with the state of
Texas uh and scare away other companies
from doing that and will you get
involved at all with the defense legally
of these companies well for for one
there there's no worry whatsoever for
several reasons one is it's it's a joke
it's really a political statement by the
mayor of New York you know you talked
about what the purpose was of that
statute on the face of the statute alone
that's not the purpose uh why the buses
are uh moving people to New York City uh
second uh what the mayor did the mayor
sued the wrong party if if the mayor
really is trying to cut down on the
number of illegal immigrants coming into
New York he needs to be doing Joe Biden
not these bus companies because it's Joe
Biden and Joe Biden's policies that's
causing the uh massive multi-million
influx into the United States that leads
to many of them wanting uh to go to New
York the third thing I will tell you and
that is the lawsuit is completely
legally baseless and and the mayor is
going to lose very badly for this very
specific reason and that is everybody
who uh is bused to or or planed to New
York
is already authorized by the B
Administration to be within the United
States legally and because of that that
means that they have the legal right to
travel wherever they want in the United
States uh and the lawsuit by the mayor
violates the United States constitutions
in several respects and the mayor is
going to lose and lose badly and I hope
he is forced to pay the legal fees for
the cost of anybody having to defend
against that lawsuit so that's just one
of the many lawsuits we'll be tracking
in conjunction with what's happening at
the board of the the doj is also suing
you suing the state of Texas over new
law that you've passed there that would
allow um police officers and law
enforcement to arrest people who are in
the state of Texas after Crossing in
illegally from Mexico would even give
some State officials the ability to
remove or to deport them um but the what
the doj is reporting to uh they're
pointing to um what the Supreme Court
did a case I covered back in 2012 uh
when Arizona had a similar state law
they shut it down they said essentially
um that the purview of immigration and
handling the border is left to the
federal government and States can't get
involved here what's your argument for
overturning that precedent with this law
well there there I have three arguments
to make sure that we are going to win
that case but first I got to point out
that this is just one of many lawsuits
that Joe Biden is filing against the
state of Texas uh they filed to
eliminate the buoys that we put in the
water that would deny illegal entry into
the state of Texas we are in the United
States Supreme Court right now where Joe
Biden is begging the United States
Supreme Court to uh to allow the border
patrol to cut uh the more than 100 miles
of razor wire that we put up that denies
illegal entry into the state of Texas
and now they're suing uh to stop this
new law that I signed this law was
crafted in a way to ensure that it was
going to be constitutional first uh it's
drafted in a way that does not conflict
with federal law the Arizona law did
conflict with federal law the state of
Texas law does not conflict with federal
law and hence that's one reason why we
will avoid the preemption allegation
made by the federal government the
second one is is preemption does not
apply uh because uh the federal
government is refusing to enforce the
laws passed by Congress because they are
not enforcing the laws passed by
Congress uh the law that we pass simply
enforces the laws passed by Congress
shanon the third reason why the Texas
case is different than the arizota case
is we are relying upon preemption
ourselves under uh article 4 section 4
and Article 1 Section 10 of the United
States Constitution that authorizes
Texas to do this okay you talk about it
that there that Texas is not taking over
uh what the feds would be doing but they
essenti say essentially you are if
you're going to arrest people in Texas
for being here illegally that that's
their purview when it comes to deciding
who to deport and how to handle
immigration in the Border they say there
is a direct Crossover with what Texas is
doing
well well shanon there's not listen you
and I are both lawyers and you know what
I'm about to talk about hopefully we
will not lose the audience here but uh
they they rely upon what's called field
preemption and what that means is that
the laws passed by Congress uh preempt
the field or the the totality uh of the
ability for states to do something
different however uh that field
preemption that the federal government
is relying upon presumes that the
federal government will be in enforcing
the law passed by Congress in this case
the federal government is not enforcing
the laws passed by Congress in fact
they're acting contrary to the laws
passed by Congress that creates the
opening uh for Texas to be able to uh
enact a law that that simply enforces
the very same laws passed by the United
States Congress all right well Governor
I'll track that we'll see if it comes uh
and winds up here at the Supreme Court
is that Arizona law did we're tracking
the razor wire case too Governor thanks
for your time thank you Shannon I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis